[Music]
- one what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on and
we are a place where we bring on really
intelligent people to talk about the
cool things that they're up to and I
help make the content relatable for you
and inspire you to build the future so
here we go today our guest is rock Rasim
what's up hey how's it going thanks for
coming on the show pleasure
appreciate it so the work of spiritual
awakenings what's doing yeah how do we
get there is that a question I'm glad
you had a question
well you know I feel like all I'm gonna
say is parrot or paraphrase all the
wisdoms of all the teachers down through
the ages either there is no there or
it's not about getting there it's about
the journey right to get there all right
so if you condense this down the
spiritual journey you know what is that
where incarnate as human beings we have
this perception rightly so of being in
form of being embodied of being in love
with life itself
but we don't often very much stop to
think about what that really is you know
what we're born into we're born into our
families and tribes and cultures but
this whole reality that we're born into
you know what is it and what is the
purpose of being here and then what is
that journey that we go on yeah I mean a
spiritual awakenings just a bumper
sticker phrase right and - yeah until
you feel it until you own it until you
start asking the questions that you
don't even know what the answers are but
you can't stop asking them there's that
hunger for connection for authenticity
for something more than just the
nine-to-five mm-hmm so I've definitely
been thinking about the essence of like
being born into a family and then just
who do you have in your life you have
yourself that you love hopefully you
love yourself and then you love your
family and hopefully there is a good
unconditional love there then you might
have a couple friends and besides that
you don't really like have that many
more people really in your life and what
is the purpose of life so what are we
even ask kids ever taught about the
purpose of life or to talk to other
people about the philosophy or about
what we're doing on this planet and how
we can work together not really too much
we're kind of just taught math science
history English literature that kind of
stuff and that that's so the spiritual
awakening bumper-sticker like people
usually like just slap it around on to
different things but but more
specifically with what your work is
about ayahuasca in five amiyo DMT and
how these help with spiritual awakening
now what exactly is so the life
journey's obviously lots of ups and
downs and finding some sort of an
actualization of the self and of the
collective together
so where does like 5mu DMT play into
that equation jump straight into the
deep end having you there right so look
I mean before you even say five Meo
deemed to me or i wass kirai I'm an
author I'm a journalist I'm a filmmaker
I've made books and films about
ayahuasca and that's a plant medicine
that comes from Peru it's native to the
jungles all through South America they
use it as a medicine for healing and
connection it also has a visionary
component the ayahuasca brew has been
Asteria OPS's copy which is divine mixed
with admixture plants the leaves like
Chuck Runa which contain in and
dimethyltryptamine which is a tryptamine
so we're getting close to what DMT is
when that's putting the brew together
and it's drunk its catharsis and a
healing modality which is usually
overseen by and facilitated by a
medicine person in Peru they call that a
cure in Sderot in the West we call that
role of shaman and that role is very
much mythologized because we don't have
them in the West because we killed them
all right we killed our medicine people
for the last five six hundred years or
more we killed the witches and the
warlocks and the herbalist and the plant
people and when the new world went back
to the old world and have found
indigenous cultures who work with plants
that
change consciousness yeah like the
psilocybin mushroom the San Pedro cactus
things like ayahuasca we the the church
who was the Empire going back to those
cultures exterminated the majority of
them and subjugated the rest and looked
at upon us the work of the devil so we
have essentially a few hundred years of
disconnects from the planet and from
medicines containing substances which
change our relationship to ourselves and
to nature
so we'll get to five Meo dean see like
tryptamines in general we pause on just
a history for just quick second and as
you explained because i don't think that
we we really grasp on to the
understanding of what civilizations in
the past i've been able to achieve with
plants and what people that are
sometimes these Wanderers that go into
plant medicine and understanding plants
and how they augment consciousness are
sometimes burned at the stake there
sometimes it's completely exiled and we
lose that sort of knowledge until the
wet like the West or the advanced world
finally was looking around in cubicles
like what the [ __ ] are we doing right
now and then they look at Peru and other
places in the Amazon and then it's like
oh wow there's all these crazy cool ways
to augment consciousness and tap into
something that is totally not the
economic and political machine but it's
something that is the divinity within me
and the divinity within us and so then
that's so cool how actually throughout
history there have been these times of
significant understanding and then at
times of a complete quelling of this
beauty in genius and then now this
turned back around and like what is this
how can we bring this into the light yes
I great so one interesting I guess
excuse me understanding or container for
that looking at the historical process
history is only like ten twelve thousand
years old you know there's different
since agriculture yeah yeah there's
different archaeologists and
anthropologists and academics one of
them like Graham Hancock quite
well-known who points to the fact that
there's evidence of ancient
civilizations you know in the the record
and even the civilizations who have
identified like Egypt you know different
dating and testing on the ruins seems to
suggest they could be older than we are
than the the narrative story we've
created for history but his story we
know history is written by the victors
but it's not that old but the human race
has you know survived since time
immemorial and potentially we've had
peaks and troughs of civilizations that
have come before that no longer remain
yes that many indigenous cultures around
the world who have been on the land in
Australia with the Aborigines yes they
say there's been 80,000 years or more of
unbroken lineage on the lands and they
have memory they have memory which they
passed down from generation to
generation the oral record of what
happened in cyclic time I mean just like
we have you know 80,000 unbroken years
yeah of little one continent on the land
yeah yeah on the land yeah family family
80,000 years old that's on you can't
even fathom that anymore yeah well we
have a five year attention span at the
most in in modern Western culture it's
usually like a five second dopamine hit
attention span in in practical reality
right but imagine what it means when as
a culture you have a vast memory of what
has gone before
and within that this is where the wisdom
comes from the wisdom of being connected
to the land connected to the planet
connected to the species and to be
stewards of the land it's no right
relationship and to know that at certain
times in large historical timeframes
there are great earth changes it's like
there's seasons right like the different
world ages in the the Eastern sort of
traditions in India and the the Vedas
they point to things like the Kali Yuga
or different cultures say there's like a
golden age a silver age a bronze age an
iron age that there's cycles of time
right so the Maya is a really
interesting example we had the peak in
western interest a few years ago with
2012 which in the Mayan calendar was
zero point zero point zero point zero
point zero in their galactic calendrical
they had many calendars which seemed to
point both within the earth and the
seasons and also stargazing culture that
knew what was out there they said had a
certain coordinate out in space they
said was what they called Hunab qu the
womb of the great mother and in 2002 at
those exact coordinates NASA discovered
a black hole right
so current astrophysics which is deeply
psychedelic right I really encourage
people looking for also physics it's
it's looking at the relationships
between all the bodies right and so you
start to realize that not just the
planet in nature but the energetic
ecology goes beyond the atmosphere into
space there's like an Iban ribbon around
the edge we never say that from vyas
civilization prior to all of our
scientific advancements was able to
identify a black hole in the night sky
they called it the womb of the great
mother now that's what I'm getting at
the current astrophysics theory
understands that the black hole sucks in
all matter and/or energy but as it does
so it excites the event horizon around
the black hole yeah and it actually then
emits galaxy-wide Jets of plasma that
have built up from the charge of
bringing everything in those Jets of
plasma discharge across galaxies and
ignite space dust which has component
chemicals and like atoms in it and they
think that's now the how stars are born
so it's true that's cool the womb of the
great mother gives birth to stars which
give birth to life right the Mayans also
said that the center of Hunab coup was
the center of consciousness so imagine
their 0.0.0.0 point zero in their
kalindra core meant that our solar
system is pointing at the center of the
galaxy and when we're pointing at the
center of the galaxy we're going above
the elliptic of the galaxy the middle
point and we're entering this arena
where we're getting bombarded distant
astrophysics terms by a whole lot more
information and by bodies of stars and
other other entities there's magnetized
100,000 times more powerful than the Sun
every second bombarding the earth so in
the energetic ecology of all these
bodies they're feeding each other and
we're now getting more signal as the
minds would say Oh consciousness so my
pet theory right I mean we're talking
about Australian Aborigines before yeah
and so many indigenous cultures all the
you know what we now think is primitive
but they had these amazing capacities to
engage with the earth and with the stars
understood cyclic time and world ages
and in the world ages there's
fluctuations of consciousness as well so
my theory essentially is an Australian
Aborigines like to call this dream time
right and I've been privileged to sit
with people that have been initiated
into Aboriginal culture which is a very
privileged esoteric body of information
you know and they don't let a lot of
stuff out but they essentially say the
dream time is coming back which is
understandable if you understand we're
going through phases of time in the
world ages right it's just natural and
so it's like it's like you know fall
winter spring and summer but on a
galactic level so what we're now the
phase in all of history has been one bar
signal one bar right and before that we
had expanded consciousness or as many
myths and legends tell us we had a type
of consciousness that had a fall we had
a fall from consciousness according to
some of the root myths and the religious
texts of many different judeo-christian
ik religions right if we marry that with
the dream time consciousness indigenous
understanding it points to the fact that
we used to have more capacity right but
it comes back to what is consciousness
and if consciousness is not just
something epigenetically centered in the
brain that we're producing consciousness
but we're receiving consciousness which
to this day scientists cannot say they
cannot discredit yes zero right yeah and
it seems to be that there's a tipping
point there more people coming around to
the idea that the brain is a receiver of
consciousness as well as a generator
within its field so imagine like you
know 26,000 years with some a the Mayan
grand orbit around the galaxy so within
the quadrants of that we've gone from
what I call five-bar galactic Godhead
signal like 5 bar signal down to one bar
and at some point we had the fall of
consciousness and we lost the plot yeah
like if you've ever been totally
head-over-heels in love that feeling or
that connection yeah right that intimacy
that sacred space of like a mother to a
child when it's taken away and the
heartbreak yeah falls in right so
imagine we had this asteroid that's the
one bar that's the one by singer so
imagine we had this expanded
consciousness which is cyclic in nature
over large tracts of world ages and time
and there our species has been there
before and there's been other golden
ages of other species we know the
approximate date dates of different
kalindra calls that the Mayan grand
calendar for this what we're talking
about there galactic calendars every
26,000 years as a full orbit so that's
this the way they're calculated they had
an advanced mathematical aptitude as
well but essentially what I'm getting at
is we had this capacity but then when it
was severed presumably like 12,000 plus
years ago and we fell into the the ache
and the complete like the the complete
you know absence of that connection then
the ego starts to kick in we don't know
how old the ego is but it seems to be
that it's a component of the mind that
obviously we need the ego is a wonderful
thing except we've we've we've misplaced
the right relationship with the ego so
when we had an expanded capacity and a
more of a cohesive connection with our
mind body and spirit and then all of a
sudden that connection dropped and all
we were left with was the mind to
survive to feel safe to to feel each
other
I mean survival mechanism kicks in it's
almost as if we have species PTSD yeah
if you look at what we've done to the
planet right that's a good way to put it
CRC's pts I know because if you look
when someone it has trauma in their
experience they start to contract either
either that it's a coping mechanism they
learn how to keep coping but within them
there's something which is shut down
and in us what's shut down is the
ability to feel yeah the ability to be
open and the ability to trust we no
longer you know the course of his story
yeah understand or feel that we are the
planet and we are the planet right we
are one very clever species amongst many
and are dwindling many because we're
killing them all off but the ego over
successive thousands of years has
hoarded it's taken it's protected and it
shut itself off from nature to create
culture which is embedded within nature
and culture is a cult it's like it's
like a
it's like a bloom which has gone all
across the planet but it's actually
starving all the oxygen like almost
literally right it's taking more than it
gives back because it no longer feels
the connection it's protecting itself
from the reality because of that
disconnect and we've cuttle together
we've huddled together we've
cannibalized each other
we've divided and conquered and we're
still acting out our trauma and that's
all of history ok let's let's let's
unpack because we have this transition
from maybe feeling a lot more and loving
and trusting and then we transition to
the state of like kind of like ego and
and money and power and greed and
corruption and logic and and man in
history masculine and now we're kind of
and there's been a lot of like
creativity and innovation like computers
and smartphones and like penicillin and
the antibiotics and all these cool
things that have helped us a lot but at
the same time there's a very there's a
usually like this lacking touch of
femininity of emotion a feeling of love
of trust across civilization and across
technology especially so now we're kind
of pivoting to that to that to that
moment to these moments as a
civilization removing this PTSD working
our way through collectively this PTSD
this trauma stroma yeah and we're
getting towards a world where we
actually have more feeling more emotion
more love and trust a couple together
with this love for innovation and
creativity and like masculine logic and
stuff either we love better or we die
yes the species that's it because what
is created the planetary emergency is us
right and not the fullness of us but the
wounded us to traumatic us to shut off
us that scared us that us that's got who
knows how many atomic nuclear bombs out
there with a finger on the trigger like
they can suicidally imagine doing that
yeah I mean how wounded are we to want
to kill ourselves and the planet right
how do we even see ourselves as
different from the planet right it's
like we have a mind and the intellectual
we have a heart with neuronal cells 70%
neuronal cells like the brain but it
feels yeah and we have the gut instinct
the third brain they say with seven
trillion cells in our microbiome which
are in gamma frequency of cohesion which
create a third brain intuition in
connection but all of those things are
overshadowed by the mind we no longer
remember how to feel so at this point
you know in nature if we are connected
to nature and she is as James Lovelock
whose coin like the Gaia hypothesis our
momma or as Pachamama as they say in the
ayahuasca tribes of the Amazon the earth
is an alive intelligent loving entity
she's the mother yes right these are
breathes if you look from satellites you
see the polar caps coming on and I know
awful to science I mean look at the
really good science people like Carl
Sagan or someone like that who really
get the interconnected interdependent
nosov the world and it's psychedelic its
psychedelic and its sacred delhi for a
crawl it's sacred for Delhi yeah right
because they understand that the the the
the impossibility of life existing in
the womb of this planet is astronomical
like it shouldn't happening it it does I
forgot to mention you mentioned nature
versus culture and it's literally
metropolis as' have become cults it's
crazy i we talk about simulation theory
where on what other rocks orbiting stars
has civilization evolved to concentrate
in these 10 million plus congregations
of people that live like that one on top
of each other in these massive
skyscrapers without any were like
redwood trees or rivers or or it were
biodegradable --zz that are the only way
to live so this is so weird that we've
taken ourselves away from nature with so
much that's why I think one of the
reasons why so many people live in
[ __ ] San Francisco because the oceans
right here you can get as close to a
metropolis while also being right next
to the Pacific Ocean and so that way you
can have like a little bit of like oh
this is why the
work effects happening here because of
course all the brilliant economies and
stuff but also like you're right next to
the damn ocean so it feels like the
culture is at least right next to nature
mmm you know they say like cities are a
virus and the thing is because we're so
ego identified because we're so
contracted into the ego because of the
separation right it's like everything we
see comes from this way out and it's as
if we even though we we're starting to
understand quite deeply the scientific
principles and the natural rhythms and
understand the world we're in we're
still seeing it from being embedded
within it and it's it's not really often
we can understand that those emanating
principles of consciousness itself like
with the Maya saying from the center of
the black hole from the who name ku the
consciousness is like a broadcast signal
now some of the better scientists and
quantum physicists and people like that
are getting very close to Eastern
mysticism in this idea and agreeing the
fact that you know consciousness is some
like everything has consciousness yes
everything is like this I connected yeah
every day everything is like an a
manifestation you know from some central
soil dog definitely does I mean the dog
has emotions that our cats have emotions
that are very [ __ ] clear and then
plants on the other hand you know can't
really tell about emotions but you can
tell that there is something going on
with the same sign and water and
slightly questionable photo velak skin
response tests with plants like hooking
them up to you know these devices which
register electromagnetic frequencies and
apparently you know the plants do react
to pain and to negative circumstances
type things in the Amazon in the
Amazonian tradition when I went down and
studied and trained with the Amazonian
curanderos who work with ayahuasca
there's also vegetal Easter's perfumer
roses different radiation agent Elise
doesn't get a fumarole
well without digressing this is so
interested there's gradiation it's like
you have a GP or your brain surgeon or a
pediatrician there's different degrees
of doctors who work with medicines but
they don't just work with psychoactive
medicines but what they do understand is
to listen and hear the the signal of
nature like this the song of nature you
have to purify your body you have to
become subtle enough to pick up the
vibrations because
our ego in mind is so strong it's just
blocking out the signal so they they
undergo a rigorous diet are giving up
sugar salt oils meats things like that
for if not years and decades when
they're training to be a cure in Sderot
a shaman so they can be so sensitive to
nature and they do it in isolation so
they can feel their resynthesizing their
whole organism not to be thinking but to
be feeling because the human organism
it's perfect when a baby pops out right
and the miracle of creation that pure
soul coming down incarnated in the form
it is perfect and it is receiving full
signals so much that it can't focus on
being in ego it takes a while to adjust
and to grow that ego being trained by
their parents you know yeah from those
crazy wolf children who live with wolves
and anyway most people are born into and
it's passed on the habit of ego but it's
not necessarily something we have to
take on board in the same way but what
I'm getting at is we need to talk about
this because this is where we were kind
of getting at and I want to make sure we
get into some of the actual medicine so
okay so we have consciousness we have
the feeling of do we've the thinking and
then we have the feeling of the heart
whatever's going on in our gut and our
microbiome with the bacterial cells and
so then there's just this whole other
aspect of our body that we're just
normally not tuning into because we're
thinking all the time now how does
medicine like five amino DMT how what
does it do to the ego so the traditional
psychedelics LSD even I mean they use
this new term entheogens which means to
awaken the divine within and from the
Greek and psychedelics is to open the
mind so they've done legal tests in the
last decade with EEG machines and MRI
machines looking at the brain and what
happens when you take psychoactive
substances so with LSD psilocybin
mushrooms things like that what they've
discovered is that these substances
switch off different regional clusters
of the brain called the default mode
Network right the dmn and it's not that
the substance is actually having the
expanded consciousness effect it's that
it's switching off the filters in your
brain stopping you from having the
expanded conscious and effect all the
time but that spectrum of full
consciousness is always there
and sensitive people tune in to that in
in tribal societies they don't have
crazy people they had sensitives who
they trained to be in service to their
community and to be the medicine people
to bridge the realms and to speak with
the spirits on behalf of healing of the
people in our culture we medicate them
because we don't want the sensitives
because we don't want to know about that
right so that's the traditional
psychedelics but what it points to is
the fact that the brain or is a receiver
of the signal and we're very fastly
learning with neuroscience and shamanic
techniques in this decade and more that
we can alter our consciousness
consciously with intention and we can
optimize and we can tune in to the
greater energetic reality that has
always been around us so typically a
child is born with full capacity to tune
in to the signal the full conscious
ability to do so and then do a being
immersed into culture into the
environment that we have in these
metropolis is usually that signal is
then squelched and brought down a lot
and then we are running in the default
mode Network we're running in this
logical structure of economic and
political machine that we don't frequent
enough the full array of signal that's
available of the interconnectivity of
different ways of thinking and
perceiving the world of understanding
the cosmos and our relations with one
another through our hearts and our guts
and everything else that then it
requires some sort of a we can work we
can get it without the use of
psychoactive substances or without the
use of deep meditations but these are
assistant assisting us to get to access
to that signal almost the whole point if
there's more give us so essentially yes
so five Meo DMT is a specific it's
almost a neurotransmitter the
tryptamines produced by the human body
in the lungs the cerebrospinal fluid
their fundamental to consciousness
itself so the gut we're talking about
before produces serotonin and we have
serrator genetic pathways which your
very fundamental to consciousness
Milutin which is in the skin pigment is
in the tryptamine family the tryptamines
are used in ayahuasca and that's why it
can be a great for the Visionaire
component as well but it's very much a
healing and cleansing and letting go the
indigenous people who have been
custodians of plant medicines understand
they don't just connect us with
consciousness they connect us with our
feeling capacity with the planet and
they remind us to plug back into the web
of life to come home right and so five
Meo is potentially the king of
psychedelic compounds and it is
endogenous to the human brain so there's
been legal tests done with tryptamines
and DMT in the 90s by Rick Strassman he
wrote a book called DMT the spirit
molecule which was made into a
documentary as well and there's other
tests going on at the moment with five
mio DMT in different organizations
around the world legally as well but
essentially what they believe and it's
still to be fully proven in human
subjects they've tested on rats they
have these amazing things where they now
grow human neuronal cells in Petri
dishes and test out tryptamines on the
the brains in a petri dish right yeah
but essentially what they've discovered
is that tryptamines in general are
potentially the thing which opens to
dreaming every night in sleep at peak
experiences like birth death and
near-death experiences they seem to be
the chemical catalysts for taking us
into the emotional visionary component
of these experiences so all through time
before the 20th century when we started
to develop electromagnetism and polluted
foods and degraded environment sensitive
people and more and more people used to
connect to you know source consciousness
the big G word you know have a feeling
of connection or have a sense even
people who have needeth experiences see
that white light tunnel that sense of
going back to home we have the
capability where designed to connect to
these deeper realms within ourselves
because everything's interconnected but
it's being degraded over time not just a
one bar signal but our lifestyle our
habits our egos have degraded our
electromagnetic capability to receive
the signal have four five boxes what
mystics still go to caves in the middle
of nowhere and just shut out the world
and go in or people are in nature they
feel better they feel like they can
receive and they can open more because
they're not getting degraded by by
civilized
civilization is killing us if you
haven't noticed right so anyway so
anyway tryptamines are native to our
being
I mean they've become very popular in
some of the medicines like ayahuasca
there's another medicine that I work
with in countries where it's legal I
lead retreats over in Mexico as well as
ayahuasca retreats in Peru which is the
bufo alvarius toad now this toad comes
from the Sonoran Desert in the north of
Mexico over into Arizona
it contains 17 or 20 different trace
elements in its glance there's over 400
species of toads in the world this is
the only one which contains five Meo DMT
so there's not an unbroken lineage like
the reefs with ayahuasca in the Amazon
but there is a modern lineage of Mexican
modern people using it having
reintroduced it to some of the Sonoran
indigenous tribes of Mexico and it is
very quickly spread across the world in
the shamanic communities of the west
piggybacking on the popularity of
ayahuasca and other antigens because it
feels like it's time for this because
the experience of five Meo which is the
experience that meditators can have
without an external catalyst is to
reveal essentially that we are the
medicine I feel like there's been a
whole generation in the West I mean this
goes back I mean how long is a piece of
string be you could go all the way back
to the 60s and LSD which basically had
to come through the lab but helped open
the mind in the 80s ecstasy came and
helped open the heart in the noughts
plant medicines including ayahuasca came
to clean out the entire body and to
reconnect the soul there seems to have
been a stepping stone over generations
which is very short in guyun time in
planetary time of if we're killing the
planet she had to get back through to us
right now
I almost feel that human species is like
one strand in the planetary biome you
know yeah it's like we're one strand all
the species are like a micro biome in
gaia herself yeah and we've gone off and
so she's trying to regulate that strand
that's going off it's like where were
the probiotics I know I have all these
substances that she secretes she
secretes the psychoactive substances the
mother these are not illegal these are
the plants and it is the most hubris
sort of assumption to think that plants
can be illegal yes like thank you
it's like saying life is illegal but
it's because people in the past have
tried to control consciousness and you
know Richard Nixon 1971 post 60s
establishment you know blowback against
the the acid revolution I have order
after they still do they're still trying
to do that you say people in the past
well look I would like to say that we
the war on consciousness is over
consciousness one mm-hmm
right consciousness one bad guys not me
right it's saying essentially there's
been you know push and pull which is
what always happens in in culture and
civilization is like there's elements
which are more progressive and elements
which hold back yada yada yada those
binaries but essentially there's been a
stepping stone getting us ready for
essentially I believe the five Meo
experience we've gone through the 60s
revolution the consciousness revolution
Palo Alto Silicon Valley ground zero you
know all these basically I feel
psychedelics acted as a psychic
lubricant to stretch our minds from
linear white-picket-fence nine-to-five
reality so we can bring through these
technologies I mean people say where do
ideas come from you know if we are
receivers of consciousness it's like
when it's time for a telephone it's time
for a telephone and multiple people get
the idea at the same time like how you
described it as a the microbiome of
Pachamama of Gaia
yeah and how there's one species us that
decided to do these culture metropolis
is and then all of a sudden Pachamama
was like what is this thing that I need
to add to the equation oh look at all
these beautiful plants that can be
leveraged in order to just unleash the
potential of the species and then now
we're we're unleashing and we had all
these increments over the last 50 years
like you said with the different types
of psychoactive its leading somewhere
right so the thing is because we're an
egoic individuated consciousness because
we've fallen from that expanded
consciousness into the contraction of
the trauma of you know what we've gone
through even when we say things like
cities we don't see the pattern we don't
see the clustering and the the way that
there's a rhythm to it if you're
visiting time-lapse footage you know of
things it's like we are nature even
though we're cloistered and shut away
we're still following the rhythms
the emanation of the life force itself
and so even when like you know a tribe
and a hamlet and a village then becomes
a town then becomes a city you know it's
scaling up but there's natural
principles at work and we think that
we're just doing what we're doing but
we're following a natural rhythm you
know there's this when not in control as
much as we think we are you know it's
like it's the ego which is always trying
to help us survive that thinks it's the
center of everything which the egos not
that anyway we'll get there so what I'm
getting to is that there's been a
gradiation and a relationship from the
planet wooing us back right and it took
like 60 years for us to go back to the
garden to go back to the plant medicines
and the entheogens versus the lab
chemicals but we had to start somewhere
right
each stepping stone is leading it's
further and further into a guy in
intimacy with nature herself and at the
culmination and the apex of that is
where we find ourselves now
the toad medicine and synthetic five Mao
has been around for quite a few decades
as well but it is the strongest ego
dissolving thing we have and this is a
really interesting thing you know back
in the 40s
LSD arrived around the same size it's
the strongest ego dissolving thing we
have yeah it's 500 DMT yes because we
need a we need a touch on this this is
so important to touch on I i I've went
through this experience several times
now five amiyo DMT and I am in love with
the eradication of ego it feels so good
to be able to tap into the oneness of
everything and away from the crazy
obsession of thinking all the time into
feeling and there's so many other ways
to do it but the way that we understand
what is truly possible within this
divine being assisted by of something
like five amiyo DMT has been I always
say the top three for so far experiences
of my life are five mio DMT 10 day
meditation retreats as with pastina and
Tony Robbins unleash the power within
those are my three favorite / most
profound experiences of my life
interesting nice graphic what I was
gonna say is that psychedelics are often
called ego dissolving materials this is
that signal that you were talking about
right but that's a class-five Meo
experience so that the tunnel the
whitelighter so yeah here's the thing
I'm not here to promote the use of
psychedelics or five Meo DMT or tide
medicine right but what I understand
from my relationship as a journalist
also filmmaker and Ron can you pull up
of the five Meo toad just pull up five
Meo toad the bavaria stone yeah yeah oh
you out we already have one ready what
what I understand it's secreted right
here from this gland right here so this
glands around this parotid glands around
the neck on the the legs and on the feet
of the toad and it's not something to go
out into nature to seek out because it
is a living creature and yeah if you
disturb it in its environment you could
kill it or you could upset its cycle
human touch on the toad can transmit
viruses it can be not good for the toad
as well it's it's something that's very
sacred and it's very dangerous in the
Sonoran Desert with not go drug
trafficking around the northern Mexico
so there are sustainable sanctuaries
farms that exist that they keep them in
very not yet there is there is a growing
network of people who do honor the
sacredness of the toad and a see that
there's a need to protect it this girl
at the Michael Pollan event he stood up
in the queue a and yelled she was like
if anyone's looking for a toad sanctuary
person that's me and she stood up and
yelled and I was thinking for a second
I'm like how can we just gather like
fifty or a hundred people that are all
in the space all with her and just have
them all work together and figure out
how to how to do we want to help with
this process as well so bad okay
continue so essentially the toad
medicine was a five Meo DMT isn't the
only substance out there which affects
our consciousness and I'm not saying
that people have to take these
substances what I'm recognizing from my
own journey is that nature is
psychedelic nature is sacred yes and we
are so disconnected that we think of
ourselves as separate from nature that
we think we are taking ayahuasca and we
are but we're not separate from the
planet which creates iowa's yeah
so people say like left-hand path
right-hand path these things are not
good it's like we have a planetary
emergency that we are largely
responsible for you know egoic you know
function yeah and time is pretty short
right yeah and so you can get to these
phases of non-dual consciousness and of
lowering the ego by meditation by other
practices by breath work by Tantra by
meditation and these are wonderful
all paths lead to central source and the
emergency contains within it the
emergence and that's what I believe is
happening on the planet at the moment
okay so all these paths of different
meditation different psychoactive
chemicals these all kind of drive us to
what what you called the source and then
from there what are within this limited
time that we have of trying to you this
emergence that we can come with to solve
the emergencies that are occurring on
the planet looks like Einstein says the
the the problem that the consciousness
which cause the problems is not going to
be the consciousness which solves them
ah and so if we understand what we've
said in this conversation about history
being you know the the canvas of our
trauma essentially and that if we're
trying to save the world from a place of
egoic consciousness we're gonna be
trying to solve a million little
problems but all of those problems are
actually a product of our consciousness
if we can come back to our Center
individually and collectively and come
back to feeling and come back to the
heart and come back to compassion and
come back home to where we know we are
that source consciousness within then
that emanation coming out of us will
solve everything because this is my
other short hair say we're not saving
the world the world is saving itself
through us through us by re-engaging the
relationship with us cuz that's the only
problem is that we're disconnected so
tapping into whether you meditation or
Tantra or I don't know any you know
whatever method gets you in touch with
yourself that is what is needed at this
time because this what is what is inside
us majority of people have forgotten so
in the five Meo experience which again
the the toad for instance acts as a
catalyst
it is smoked so it bypasses the gut it
is absorbed through the blood-brain
barrier incredibly quickly within
seconds because the brain knows what to
do with it because we produce our own
five Meo DMT right essentially you're
saying before what does it do
scientifically like the default mode
Network but a little bit different it
lowers the frontal lobes of the brain
it increases coherence to the point of
hyper coherence of all the network
activity of the brain
so you everything comes online and the
ego drops out of the picture right and
we don't want to kill the ego we need
the ego but the ego needs to know it's
not in control it's not always needed
when the mind lets go
we lower the defenses and in indigenous
understanding they say we have an
energetic body an emotional body in a
physical body and as we go through life
humans store their stresses and traumas
it stores in the energetic body it comes
into the emotional body heart aches and
woes and all that stuff and that those
nexus points with the physical body
that's where sicknesses often develop
and so when we let the ego in the mind
down all of that stuff can come up and
come out for healing with a good
practitioner to help hold space for you
in a ceremony and our natural innate
capability like a newborn baby I call it
you know five Meo is like I call it
God's factory reset it's like a complete
refresh potentially that then aligns you
with your inner self and that you
receive the signal I'll call it a
Galacta bation right so the frontal
lobes go down the mind goes down the
best maps i've got i've seen for this
the vedic maps of samadhi their sense of
liberation or one that's that sense of
non-dual unity consciousness in the
Vedic Maps they say that what we think
of it's the mind or the ego is like wind
on water like ripples ripples busy-busy
always thinking even when you're falling
asleep still thinking we're never free
of it right and so when that lowers we
can go deeper into the ocean of the mind
itself what the Vedic maps called sattva
the depth of that the ocean of mind
itself and we can reach Atman or our
true nature so the mind goes down the
heart and the the stomach instinct those
networks because they're networks as
well they open
they connect to everything in the unity
field and they feel the signal and that
feeling is like the heart of a star it's
like you know the poet Rumi said the
drop rejoins the ocean where now
individual nature of holding on and
thinking where this lowers and just
surrenders and lets go it opens up this
capacity within ourselves for the drop -
remember the ocean and that is within us
it's like Buddha nature within us this
is what all the eastern mystic texts
have been saying and it is now firmly
within our grasp to access very rapidly
with the power of five Meo
and with the wisdom and respect and
sacredness to do it right so I'm not
suggesting people rush out there and
look for five Emmy you have five Emmy Oh
in your very nature you could very well
just meditate and find that ideally an
antigenic experience like five mio DMT
to activate the the person's full bio
electrical field married with a
meditation practice and a grounding sort
of environment to maintain that
vibration because people find once
they've had the five Meo experience it
doesn't necessarily go away this isn't a
tab of acid you taken it wears off eight
hours later this is your deeper being
being revealed and then when the mind
comes back online and it does the mines
there but anytime you learn to lower the
mind and the defenses that vibration is
still active within you right and it's
like as more and more people come online
and have their activations through
whatever method through breath work or
Tantra or five Meo
it's like more and more people are
connecting and I call it a Samadhi mesh
network the signal gets stronger the
more people will have this experience
however they get there it's almost as if
in the season of consciousness where in
where we're receiving 5 bar signal like
things are getting really interesting on
earth so the emergency we're seeing is a
direct player form of our egoic
construct over time coming to a
crescendo and it's not looking good
right
attached to the outside forum come back
to the feeling come back to the heart
come back to the compassion come back to
your true nature it's perfect everything
is perfectly orchestrated because
everything is incredibly interconnected
we are within the matrix of Pachamama of
Gaia she is in the matrix of the solar
system within the galaxy within the
universe all of space-time within the
container of source consciousness which
creates the universal being somehow
through its mysterious nature and it's
somehow outside and within I never used
to be but I do consider myself a mystic
because there's no other language I can
have to describe this
I'm not even necessarily drawing on the
maps of old I've come across them but if
and when you have this experience it
reveals itself to you in in ways that
are beyond words and beyond language in
feeling in a knowing which just
downloads and is received right that's
my political activation thing thank you
that's our 15-minute time all right
school activation so okay the droplet in
the ocean I'm really liking the analogy
there so so when I am going through the
whatever awakening processes there are
that take us to the source it's it's the
droplet understanding that it's part of
the ocean and it's also the the
deactivation of the default mode Network
v the activation of all the different
aspects of our interdisciplinary
understanding of reality that can then
awaken us even further it's the it's the
the proper way to do this though a way
to do it through facilitators through in
in areas that we retreat centers there
there's um there's it's a medicine it's
a healing process it's it's a in the
world has PTSD its includes earth PTSD
that's species PTSD that's going on and
we're going through a process of
understanding feeling tapping
back into our hearts tapping back into
our guts tapping back into our bodies
and being able to feel and love and
trust and in doing so we're gonna be
able to prosper collectively in a much
better way hopefully hopefully we'll we
got to work we got a well we got to work
we got to work on it cuz like you like
you were referencing it's like we we are
Pachamama we are Gaia we are everything
- yeah it's forgotten who and what we
really are and we've been telling
ourselves a story for tens of thousands
of years here and it's not a good story
because it it's blocked us from the
greater story that we're in and it's
time to come home to that greater story
you know like all paths basically all
religions that they're caught know this
central truth at the heart of the story
the mystery at the heart of the story
and the mystery is alive it's well it's
radiating the signal and it wants us to
know that and everyone to their own
capacity I mean we say that you said at
the start this awakening thing it's a
new age bumper sticker another phrase
right what is the awakening it's a verb
it's a doing thing it's a process it's a
relationship so I like to think that if
we're in this cosmic season and we've
shifted gears since 2012 and now are in
the new elliptic and on this new
energies coming in and everyone's
feeling and then it seems to be that
planetary civilization is collapsing in
front of our eyes and we're getting more
and more denialist about that very fact
yeah at the same time you know there's
the analogy you throw a a frog into a
pot of boiling water and it jumps
straight out but if you slow boil it it
just stays in the water and it dies a
lot that's what's happening we're slow
boiling on planet Earth
but some of us are freaking out and
waking up the pressure is like coal
being squeezed into diamonds right but
very very fast now that pressure that's
happening on planet Earth is the
awakening process and you don't need any
medicines to do it we are the medicine
but life will find a way to break you
open right because in that trauma in the
wound in the opening that's when we can
release
and we can let go and we shift and we
change and we're not going to change
we'd proven we're not going to change
unless we get a slap in the face as a
species right that's what's coming it
doesn't necessarily have to be
apocalyptic but it is going to be
transformational so everyone's feeling
the energy it's almost like when you're
out camping you're in a tent and
sunlight comes over the cliff and it
comes you know it starts warming up some
people get up they meet the dawn the
early adopters other people like know
I'm awake now I'm gonna stay here and uh
stay here but you're feeling it
everyone's feeling that something big is
happening right big awakening them the
big awakening and everyone comes to that
at their own time you cannot awaken
anyone people awaken when they're ready
when they trust when they feel like they
can open yeah so more and more there's
been a generational tsunami of interest
in the shamanic medicines and the plant
medicines in the toad medicine and
they're very quick pathways to very
rapid awakening they're not for everyone
but as more and more people do awaken
through whatever pathway a critical mass
of that vibrational awakening people is
coalescing yes and that's forming I
think like something the Samadhi mesh
network the idea that you know some
people are holding that vibrational
frequency you know so I as a journalist
I interviewed this religious scholar
almost two years ago and he was telling
me about the Rigveda and their soma and
their antigen they had this is the
Indian holy book two thirds of it
mentioned the psychoactive substance
which they revered called the soma but
through that essentially they had
eventually a golden age but they had a
society potentially which understood
these different levels of Samadhi or
egolessness States non-jew or egoless
states right so here's my little
condensed metaphor imagine thousands of
years ago you have a monastery and in
the monastery there's like village
around it and they're in a blissful
everyday you know a vibration inside the
monastery have a level two vibration of
like non egoic tuning in meditating you
have a third ring of people in the
monastery who what they call sambhoga
bliss body level three samadhi feeling
lowering the ego feeling that
connectedness in the web of life then
have people that are in stage 4 samadhi
concentric rings within concentric rings
they're in basically what they call will
stage 4 is like the witnessing when them
the mind goes all the way going and all
you can hold is the enormity of source
consciousness that oh my god oh my god
oh my god
but there's no thought it's just
receiving the signal right on the event
horizon of deep sauce yeah and there's
one monk in the center of that monastery
within the concentric circles of other
layers of consciousness who has given
his whole being up to God to Stage five
what they call seedless Samadhi no
attachment fully letting go and
interestingly enough this is based on
some of the the ancient texts called oh
the cart of the kama sutras yeah
no the conversation it's by Patanjali
the Yoga Sutras Yoga Sutras kama sutras
really there are sex
yeah well the yoga sutras are actually
all about energetic activation
potentially in the body and all that as
well all those Eastern mysticism stuff
is very good oh but essentially these
texts say that Sutra is to weave you
know to make a weaving so essentially
what they were saying was vibrationally
energetically there are levels of
consciousness not in the mind but
energetically in the being which go from
us to deeper astral levels connecting up
to source and when we dip into that
fully and come back we make a weaving
and we then therefore anchor a little
bit of that more higher vibrational
higher Bardo heavenly right into the
earth through our bodies we are the
vessel so people that have had the five
Meo experience you know I'd like to say
to them your body is a temple it's not
just a bumper sticker again you wage
bumper sticker it's that this is
designed to hold that vibration they're
a source country like the newborn baby
and you're stitching right back into the
Society's fabric or coming back in but
then your energy is affecting everyone
around you everything everything else
when you fully open into these levels of
Samadhi you create a singularity point
like in the heart of an atom or in the
heart of the black hole like you know
blue again where consciousness can
emanate and the relationship then when
the ego comes back online with the
hardened with the the gut instinct and
with the
all body organism and with source
consciousness within over time shapes
you to be karma to be less reactive to
be more open and more connected like
optimize your entire being and then we
start to shift from any go ik culture
well you know they say they go it goes
from ego to we go to we go we go right
so it's about all of us it's about how
can I help how can I be in service you
know how can I see and feel right to
feel that you are another I and that
tree is another I yeah and that
Pachamama is me that I am in the mother
and I am one of the microbiome of the
planet and we're all in this survival
game together and that it's what's going
to change the world the consciousness of
us remembering who and what we really
are so well said right oh man
and there's this delicate kind of
balance that we have to have as we move
forward into that which is that
sometimes the ego does have to rise up
and have to be a part in building that
future of we go because if we don't do
that along the way yeah as you say
dreams don't work unless you do but
first you need the vision first you need
to remember what the goal is and really
remember what's life all about it's like
it's about being it's about remembering
that we are this temple we are this
construct this simulated construct to
hold this information I believe that
source consciousness didn't make the
whole reality just to watch it from the
outside like another episode of the
Kardashians or whatever right
Kardashians I didn't know never what
you're right but it's like it's it's
grooming the vessel to inhabit that
consciousness to then Express that
consciousness like like the mystery and
like the mother earth like all of
reality we are we're not just connected
to it we are the center point of that we
are the fulcrum point of that and it's
starting to get very juicy here on
planet Earth yes and what we can do
with that both through technology and
neuroscience and shamanism what I like
to call neuro Sharmini neuro shamaness
because potentially once you've had this
experience through whatever modality of
recognizing where the ONS mapped and
it's man it's a science there is no
feedback to and meditation techniques to
anchor that ability right and then I
mean and again nature's done this before
you look at look at look at the insects
right individuated beings all working
within a swarm of the hive minds and if
you look at like Facebook every day of
the week and you see five thousand
people in your feed and we're getting a
little dopamine hits but it's like we're
starting to be totally decentralizing
it's like blockchain I got this whole
riff on God's blockchain so it's like
it's like this decentralized network of
trust which connects to everything right
I mean that's consciousness yeah so it's
like we're actually being groomed to get
bigger to hold more of that signal so
interest through our technology we've
built through our ego and through the
trauma but it's all being stepping
stones to prepare us for what's coming
you know because there's what's coming
is gonna require all of the war journey
that we're putting in right now to to be
in a beautiful light of functioning
light leveraging technologies like
blockchain distributed and decentralized
technologies also to whatever neuro
shamanism seems very interesting to me
because then it becomes like more of an
objective truth rather than a subjective
truth if you can show that oh look at
all these fMRI Zoar EG scans of the way
that people's brains what they exude
when they're on these different
experiences that guide towards the
source and look at what they do what
they feel when they leave they turn into
we go they still keep some ego for that
good for execution and stuff but it's
all about the we go together
unlike the sixties we have the
technology now to fully understand what
these substances are doing and not just
the technology but I think we have the
emotional maturity to handle this as a
culture you know it's been 60 years of
this
psychedelic revolution the
medicalization of psychedelics is coming
back in as well their technology to help
us optimize and find these aspects
within ourselves
everything's dovetailing to support us
in feeling safe enough to open to the
full spectrum of consciousness which has
always been there that we've shut the
aperture through our trauma and we can't
just you can't force people open but if
we can trust the process then we can re
sensitize and we can we can rediscover
that vibration and that love which is at
the heart of everything and it's the
whole point of everything so the
aperture of our ability to tune into the
signal has been closed over time and now
it's slowly being reopened again I'm
really enjoying the analogies all right
let's run you through a couple of these
simulation questions on our way out
let's throw the first one up is what do
you think is the most beautiful thing in
the world a newborn baby mmm why because
it's got everything it is everything no
one can tell it what to do
it's feeling that full spectrum signal
all the time and that raw pain and
beauty and joy of being alive it hasn't
learned to protect itself yet it's open
yeah yeah I wonder what babies are gonna
look like in a couple decades once
Pachamama goes through more of this
awakening what the babies will look like
and then what they'll be like when
they're five and ten and twenty five
years old
as we start trusting and feeling and
loving more what that transitions gonna
look like well I don't know if they
gonna look differently but they may feel
and that's I mean well we as a
civilization will I'm excited for that
feeling okay I have a follow-up to this
question which is do you think we're
alone in the cosmos and we have a
beautiful deep field image we're lonely
in the code loudly and we're not alone I
don't think you know essentially I I'm
not an alien conspiracy I'm this is trip
dad Australian mystique but essentially
what ice
I see the same principles in nature as
above so below right I see the things
like the reincarnation cycle or that
going into source consciousness cycle is
like a condensation cycle of spirit and
energy and I think that and I feel and I
know that the energetic envelope and the
principles of nature extend beyond our
planet to all the rest of the universe
right and you know it's like if life can
happen here
odds are life can happen with the right
conditions anywhere totally so I don't
believe we're alone but we're lonely we
are lonely because again we've shut off
yeah and we want to connect and also we
don't even understand what life is we
think it has to look like us you know
it's like I mean there's a I think
there's other lonely civilizations out
there that maybe have got it together
enough to look out for their younger
brothers and sisters and to reach out
you know but again you can't awaken a
species before its time so when we
awaken then we can hear the signal and
they can come in mm-hmm what do you
think about this this is our last
question do you think and look at this
you see how it's interesting we have a
little like little delay going on there
- I think I saw this on Rick and Morty
yeah yeah so so so what do you think
about stuff like this you see how
there's that delay going on do you think
we're in a computer simulation you know
this has come up to me quite a bit
lately in San Francisco talking with
people about this but I mean it's just
another label like in in another
language or culture that say samsara
that say the illusion yes we're in this
yes this is real and it's an illusion in
the sense of it's not everything it's
not what we think it is you know even in
quantum physics which can be grossly you
know misquoted and misaligned but they
have this idea of the implicit and the
explicate and that there's an
originating reality which is projecting
this whole reality as a hologrammatic
sort of projection from the originating
reality so I mean I think so many
systems so many religions and so many
so many paradigms basically all agree
that we're a simulation it's just that
we've created a new label for the the
meme du jour right and we say it's a
simulation and it's like and yeah it's a
simulation I would say what's the
purpose of the simulation I mean why do
we incarnate and why does it run an
algorithm to create life to then create
more and more and more complexity to
then create more and more quest for
meaning until we get to some point where
there's got to be a purpose to the
simulation mm-hmm and then maybe it is
just so that we can run one ourselves
and then look at us ourselves in that
same moment and be like now we just made
another layer did the whole thing indeed
indeed
the beauty of five Meo DMT and the
beauty of the whole journey of opening
up the aperture and getting more of the
source into ourselves and then raising
our own vibe so that way we can vie
better as we go moving forward yeah and
you know just like to remember again
that this is a process underway it's a
relationship and these have all been a
lot of pretty hyper condensed concepts
and words which have been feeding the
ego and the minds right and this is
something like falling in love we could
be here talking about love and sex and
what goes where and all the terms and
the labels but to do it and to feel it
yeah is the whole purpose of it exactly
overintellectualizing things is not
going to get us to the actual feeling of
the heart and the and the gut and and
and of love and trust and and we go that
actually comes from the practice of
experiential wisdom like you're an
experienced journalist and that way you
can actually get to the point of feeling
this the true source within you and then
also within us together
yeah and that's that's the thing it's
like when you start to fall in love
I mean maybe one partner or the other
gets more intensity but the thing is
there's a moment
where you have to be vulnerable where
you have to trust and you have to go
with the process and some people have
been burnt before and retract and have
all their layers and you know issues or
whatever but there's a point within
which you have to let it unfold and
unravel and unroll and and enjoy that
right yeah so it's the same with
consciousness there is a process
underway and our minds are only gonna
get us half of the way there we have to
open the heart and we have to feel and
we have to trust that it's not the ego
it's the we go that's in control and
that's what's coming through Oh bless
evolution and that we even got to this
point and bless us as we move forward in
this world and bless people like you for
doing work that's crucial thank you Rach
thank you so much for being on our show
it's been a pleasure with us thank you
very much
greatly appreciate it okay brother yes
thank you brother everyone thank you so
much for tuning in we greatly appreciate
you if you guys had a good time make
sure to subscribe leave a comment below
with some of your thoughts make sure to
LIKE share the content with other people
and make sure to build with it you know
we always say that and if you are to
experience psychedelics make sure to do
them responsibly do them with
facilitators and do them in a very
trusted way please
also let's get there together let's
let's build up our our following our
subscribership join us on patreon to
help us grow and links in the bio to all
of rack's work AIA awakenings shamans of
the global village a very very good
content go watch that content please
support him in his in his journey as
well thank you Ron are producing partner
thanks everyone for tuning and we
greatly appreciate and we'll catch you
soon peace
[Music]
[Music]